The moons of Mars explained.
Mars has two Boone's Phobos and Deimos.
They are really tiny.
How tiny compared to Mars or our own moon?
Pretty tiny,
although tiny, is a
matter of opinion. There.
Surface areas or close to some of the
smallest states on earth like Luxembourg
and Malta or their Phobos and
[inaudible] are in no way lightweight.
In reality,
their gravitational pull isn't even
strong enough to bring them into spherical
form, so they look more like
huge potatoes than moons.
The most popular theory of that origin
is that they were once part of the
asteroid belt until Jupiter's massive
gravity kick them out of it so Mars could
catch them.
Phobos orbits Mars as an average
distance of 9,400 kilometers.
Once every seven and a half hours,
it's on a collision course and gets two
meters close to Mars every year in 50 to
100 million years.
It will either be ripped to pieces by
Mars is gravity and be transformed into a
beautiful ring or it will crash into Mars.
The energy released in this
collision would kill everything
on the small Panisse.
So if there are humans on Mars,
by then,
they should build very strong bunkers.
Smaller diamonds, on the other hand,
is slowly escaping Mars.
Eventually it will fly off into space
and leave a lonely rev planet behind.
So in a few hundred million years,
Mars will be moonless and on its own,
unless it manages to catch itself.
Another asteroid.